what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I'm going to be
reacting to an Andrew take clip talking
about why men should never be married
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
um also guys leave a comment let me know
what Andrew Tate should I react to next
and make sure you like the video that's
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these live streams as
you already know if you have watched two
or more of my videos and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
all right pull it up King you know the
story told about you know one day you
come home Patrick bed Davis yes your dad
comes up to and says Andrew I'll see you
in a couple weeks and he's out right in
the context of what happens when there's
a conflict and we all react in three
different ways fight flight freeze yeah
in that context your daddy's flight yeah
he runs obviously I don't want to deal
with it I'm out of here I'm gonna do my
own thing okay in America a lot of that
is happening right now where it's a
singly single parent household kids are
being raised without a mom and dad being
there and it's just one mom you know Mom
trying to do both and these boys you
know yeah my mom couldn't tell me what
to do from a very once my parents got a
divorce yeah I'm a single mother raising
me I've seen my dad every other week so
it's not like he has direct influence to
discipline me until I went into the
military yeah how much of that like if
you were to go back and think about what
if your dad didn't take the flight
approach what if your dad took the fight
approach what if your parents were
together would it have made a difference
in you and how do you view you know the
idea of fathers being there with Mom and
Dad together family nuclear family
nucleus because a lot of times oh this
is so interesting that's such a good
question so the marriage no longer has
you know the the the what it once had
you know like kids are better off being
raised with a mom and dad how do you
process that yourself because you became
successful not being land Patrick land I
wanna I wanna know environment correct
so do you see this as well it depends
there's exceptions to the rule how do
you process it I think it's a fantastic
environment and I think in an idealistic
world that's the way it would be I think
the reason it's not happening today is
that I don't think many men actually
benefit from marriages or relationships
anymore and people are always going to
have to require some degree of incentive
I think that we've set up the world now
in a way where men are seen as worker
droids they're expected to go work all
day come home uh clean up as well share
the cleaning with the woman not have any
not no meal prepared for them not have
any authority over the household and
just and just be a worker Droid and be
sad and I don't think that many people
understand that men are intrinsically
wired to desire respect amongst our
peers and in our environments this is
why CEOs work so hard because they get
respect in their company this is why we
all want so much money and fast cars and
state is an influence because we're
respected men desire respect like we
desire oxygen and if a man's coming home
to a household where he doesn't feel any
respect he's not going to want to be
there for very long and I think the way
you fix this is you need to understand
that many well I think that one we I
think just as a group we as women need
to improve and I think that's something
like we always talk about how men need
to improve but we never talk about how
we as women need to improve and like the
first things first
um I think a lot of women have not
learned a basic level of respect for men
and I think there's a lot of women that
struggle with this I think we also a lot
of us are overweight like come on y'all
we got to lose the weight but on top of
that we need to build systems that
incentivize men to actually get married
um so one of that is women becoming
better wives but the other part of that
is creating laws that actually
incentivize men to get married rather
than make it a huge risk for men don't
have an incentive to be in the housing I
think that it's actually would be quite
easy for a woman in fact there's a
couple women who even say this on
YouTube I can't remember their names but
it'd be quite easy for a woman to make a
man really happy with super basic things
just go up to your husband and say Hey
you know more about this what do you
think about this that would make most
men's World and there's so many sexless
marriages out there when men work their
ass off and they come home to a sexless
marriage and kids who don't [__] even
like if you were to just even ask him
this question about some asinine bullet
a lawnmower purchase for example he
would feel so happy to feel like the man
of the house that's what men need they
need to feel like all this work I'm
putting in all this [__] I'm going
through I'm respected for it as soon as
a man feels like he has no respect
that's the absolute end of a man's
interest or a man's tolerance of a
situation I think this is the reason
it's happening I think I know a lot of
men who completely love their wives they
love them with all their heart they die
for her but he's just not respected in
his house he doesn't get to be the man
of the house that's so sad and I think
sometimes like women we don't really
realize how like especially like I'll
see I'll see men who after like they're
married for a couple years just become
like a shadow of who they used to be and
it's really sad to watch because the
woman just has all the power in the
relationship
um and I don't know if it's something
that like the woman knows she's doing
consciously or or what but I I know what
he's talking about it's really sad for
her like does he need to go earn it or
is it on her to provide it it's a
culmination of both I think it's
certainly on him to earn it but also the
Matrix programming is counter team yeah
that's true like in every single in
every single TV show we see on TV the
dad's a a deadbeat or a doofus or
something and the woman's the smart one
so it's like I I genuinely think that
male logic is a gift from God and that
as women like we get so emotional
um within certain times like when we're
feeling really emotional we cannot see
straight and it's like the men that are
supposed to come in and help and like
guide us but the problem is the
programming is telling us that men
aren't there to guide this that we don't
need men that we're The Logical ones
when it's just not how we're wired I
mean there's a reason we got so much
debt ladies there's a reason there is a
reason like I got lucky
um you know and I remember actually
having this conversation with my dad and
they're gonna call me spoiled in the
comments but it's fine my Dad paid for
my college right so I got really lucky
where I had a dad that paid for my
college but I remember I got a lot of
scholarships for my first school okay
and I was a volleyball player and I
played there but I really didn't like
the team the team kind of bullied me a
bit I was freshman of the year for
volleyball so I came in I kind of
thought I was hot [__] and I was hot
[__] in all honesty but the team just
did not like me I was kind of cocky and
and rightfully so oh you know but so uh
what happened was I transferred schools
because basically because the team kind
of bullied me and
um you know I mean if you ask them I
probably deserved it you know I was
pretty cocky but but I went to a more
expensive school that probably would
have left me in debt had my dad not paid
for it now that's a really illogical
decision to switch schools based on the
way I felt and based on other people
um and I actually preferred the first
school I was at so and I ended up being
okay like the second school I still
liked but like am I remember my dad kind
of was saying are you sure whatever and
I still end up transferring and it was
fine but
um long story short had I actually
reaped the consequence of that decision
I'd probably be in debt to this day and
it's like we don't think things long
term like a lot of times we want to make
decisions now based on how we feel
instead of thinking the long term and I
genuinely think it's a gift from God
that God gives men the ability to see
long-term where like women typically we
don't really see it it's trying to tell
and that you shouldn't be allowed to be
the man of the house that you shouldn't
be allowed to have any kind of authority
in any regard you shouldn't be allowed
to be able to say what happens The
Matrix programming saying the absolute
opposite all the time and if that's
getting into your woman and you don't
have that much influence and that's
getting to all your children you know
right and so like the average person's
been six hours a day on the phone who
has more influence over your girl you
who like say you work at nine to five or
whatever so you might see her in the
morning at night you and like how often
are you really taught like do you want
to talk after a long day no so you're
hanging out after work
but all day she's the average girl's on
her phone six hours a day so this is
what we're we're taking in where the men
don't realize oftentimes like how much
that influences us because again women
are more susceptible to propaganda so
men might see the same ad but it doesn't
influence him as much watch influence
now you're coming home to a household
where everyone just thinks you're the
dude who should just [__] work you're
just a worker Droid you're the slave
you're the robot and your feelings don't
matter and your Authority doesn't matter
and get [__] and this is this is very
conscious if you watch any Netflix show
the mother is the smart one and the man
is the bumbling idiot correct turn on a
show I dare you turn on a family show
the mother is the one hey hey calm down
I'm smart and the man's the beer watch
any of these shows
Married with Children they're reducing
they're reducing demands and just
bubbling it in and it's very hard I
think for a lot of men to accept being a
position of constant disrespect I'll
tell you this now if I had to choose a
long lasting marriage with a woman who
loved me or a woman who truly respected
me I might choose respect over love even
though they're the same thing for a
woman because she loves you if she
respects you by default but if I had to
choose I'd choose respect what would you
pick you pick respect over love this was
part of my red pill journey I didn't
realize that that like men view I do now
but I didn't at the time realize like
that men view respect as love like it's
more important to them than love I've
been through too much and worked too
hard because the thing is when we're
outside in the world well
almost always constantly battling
competing trying to force that respect
to be given to us right so it's kind of
crazy when you come home and the person
who is meant to be the closest to you
who you've let down all your walls for
who's who has access to everything about
you doesn't give you that respect that's
like that's like so what's the point of
doing all of this outside and then to
come home to face and even worse battle
it's just weird I think I I think evil
women can destroy men more so than like
anything like have you ever seen a guy
that's in like a dead end marriage for
like five ten years he becomes like a
shadow of his former self it's really
sad that's the thing men can't destroy
men men a man can end another man he can
delete another man but only a woman can
destroy a man yeah because it's like we
have like men have like The Logical
superpower where women have the verbal
superpower and they're like manipulative
I got like you know how men can like
have an aggress they're like they can be
aggressive at their worst where women
can be crazy manipulative at our worst
through too much in day-to-day life to
come home to my house and be having
battles over asinine I take care of you
and I love you with all of my heart I
would die for you if someone broke into
this house I would Engage The Invader
and die I please just cook dinner
please just cook dinner
like what do you want from me what more
can I do for you like and once they feel
disrespected this is not other thing
about the world that a lot of people
don't understand it's disrespect that
will drive a man to the most heinous of
crimes it's disrespect yeah that's so
true oh my gosh people always argue over
respect especially oh gosh it's like
they'll justify the craziest behavior
I'm not even talking about in a marriage
but like it's like weird because my mom
always raised me to like give people the
benefit of the doubt so like if somebody
you know said something or something I
took is rude she'd be like you don't
know what kind of day they're having
just give people the benefit of the
doubt but I've seen people that aren't
raised in that way where they just are
very hyper sensitive to like disrespect
you know they take everything as
disrespect and it's so crazy because
it'll be like to me like the smallest
things will Elevate so fast over
so-called like disrespect but okay
that's the school shooter [__] it's
disrespect that makes men go to jail for
life sentences it it's disrespect when
you go okay this is one thing they don't
talk about a lot of times dudes commit
heinous crimes and family courts that's
what happened to that Chris dude who
killed his family and his wife and his
daughters now look at this is he
shouldn't have did this okay but what
happened was the wife said that she was
gonna leave him and not let him see the
kids and basically then this man just
like Snapped and went crazy and killed
everybody and a lot of guys do that
where the woman is like dragging him
through the family court system so
she'll like throw an abuse allegation at
him she'll throw
um she won't like she'll she'll not let
him see the kids for like a year or
whatever and the dude tries to go to
court where he thinks it's like a fair
system that he has a fair shot and then
he goes to court being a good dad
realizing he has no fair shot and these
men off like sometimes they'll they'll
kill themselves but other times they'll
commit really heinous crimes and the
media will paint them as these like bad
guys guys that were always horrible but
they don't talk about like what drove
them to commit that crime and that's not
me saying that it's okay it's like
clearly not okay but you know we have to
talk about it's a real problem truly
disrespect the man in a public and
permanent way that's when they switch
that's why I'm so respectful in public
you don't know who you're talking to he
might want his last straw and you're
just disrespecting hey you're a [__]
[__] anyway you're skinny mother [__]
you you don't know that might be the
last time he heard it
bad enough you don't know disrespect is
dangerous right and in a household where
you're constantly just
um
that's true [__] a man he's gonna end
up depressed and sad for even accepting
it men just want to feel respected it's
not that hard to do it's Andrew's such a
good speaker he is he doesn't he he is
such a good speaker if you truly assist
anyone watching this if you truly love
your man it would be so easy for you to
just make him feel respect it doesn't
even take actions you can do with basic
words ask his opinion on something big
and mop once in a while and because
we're supposed to be Superman and we
purport ourselves as Superman and we're
stoic but we talked earlier about how we
still feel everything so when you're a
strong man especially they're like ah
he's fine he's fine he's fine he's fine
be nice to the dude you'd be surprised
how far you get but this is why I think
men walk out marriages because they're
like you know what I'm not getting any
respect here I get more respect from
this [__] stripper 18 year old for
throwing money at her that I do giving
money to my own oh my gosh it is so
crazy talking to sex workers about their
experiences with men because there are
so many that'll tell me that the men
don't even really Comfort the sex they
come for that that like that basic level
of respect to someone to like listen to
them or you know act like they're paying
it's so sad it is so sad where am I
being respected well at least she's
smiling at me she ain't smile at me in
years if you enjoyed this video and you
want to watch the entire podcast she
hasn't smiled to me in years wow Andrew
Tate is so great he
like I always
from
his perspective and it's actually so
crazy how well thought out all of his
ideas are uh so let me know what you
guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out how important is
respect to men leave a comment below
like the video subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time